okay I guess we can get started so
thanks again thank you so much for
joining us my name is Sanjeev Gupta
I'm from the tensorflow team in Google
and this talk is about machine learning
and JavaScript I also have my colleague
Bing here and he will go present with me
so again thanks and welcome so you know
we're seeing yeah we are seeing machine
learning is beginning to have a really
big impact in almost all fields of life
around us right every day we see major
news headlines we see new breakthroughs
whether it's in transportation
healthcare Environmental Sciences all
kinds of applications even arts and
creativity where problems that were
really really difficult to solve just a
few years back are now being solved in
very impactful ways and very significant
ways by these kinds of you know new
computational approaches and new ways of
using computer systems maybe just a
quick show of hands how many of you are
actively practicing machine learning or
have some familiarity with machine
learning okay
so a relatively small number because
many of you are somewhat new to the
field let me just take a couple minutes
and introduce some terminology here and
and this will give you a flavor of why
these kinds of methods are becoming so
popular right so in most of classical
programming right when we are trying to
solve a problem or write a program for a
computer to solve a problem the way we
have usually done this is that we first
come up with these rules and we try to
write explicit code to codify those
rules right so for example if you are
trying to write a program that takes
images and tries to detect whether it's
an activity of let's say walking or
running or bicycling you might come up
with some features or rules to describe
that one way to do that might be that
let's measure the speed of the person if
the speed is less than some number then
we call this walking if the speed is
more than that number maybe it is
running right so you come up with these
kinds of rules and use implement a
computer program to to solve the problem
that you want
solve the issue with these approaches is
that they very soon run into limits
right you encounter situations where
your new rules no longer work and even
if your rules work well for the problem
you are trying to solve they are
generally not generalizable or
extensible to a slightly different
problem that you want to solve another
time right so that's where classical
programming runs into its limits like in
machine learning it turns this whole
concept sort of on its head it turns it
upside down and the way you approach
this is that what if I had some examples
where I already know the answers and
what if I can feed a lot of these
examples and answers so we call this
training data and answers on that
training data into a computer program or
a model and this model has the property
that it can learn from these examples
that it has fed so that it can come up
with what these rules are right and
these rules may be in a form that humans
can understand or it may be in some
abstract form that a computer program is
choosing to describe that problem so
this becomes a very generalizable way of
solving a problem and so in practice the
way you do that is you collect a lot of
training data and you have that data
labeled this as these are called human
generated labels you feed it into a
machine learning program or a model and
then outcome these rules or a trained
models so this is the training phase of
the machine learning process and once
you have trained a model now so this is
some representation of the model now you
can feed new data into this model and
then that model is ready to give you new
answers or new predictions on this model
right so this is called the inference
phase so this is sort of the most you
know at a high level conceptually this
is how a machine learning way of solving
a problem will look like so just to look
at this little bit visually let's say
you are trying to classify images this
is sort of what's happening there right
so a model is a collection of layers or
and all these layers are these are just
computational blocks right each layer
and each element in that layer is just
doing a very simple math operation it's
taking in some numbers it's multiplying
those numbers with some other number
and it's producing a new output and you
do all this and you feed this forward
and you wire this model so that when an
image is fed in it produces an output
that is close to the output that we
expect so if you feed in an image of a
cat we want all these things to flow in
and the output of our model should be a
number that we designate as indicating
cat if it is not cat then we calculate
an error or a difference and we
propagate that error back through our
model and we sort of tweak or adjust all
the parameters of our model until we get
the right answer right and we keep on
doing this for lots and lots of examples
and then we have a trained model for
that particular task that we are trying
to solve so this is sort of how machine
learning approach of solving a problem
works right now the reason why machine
learning is really taking off now and it
has become such a important part of
problem solving today is for three main
reasons first is that as we just saw it
relies on availability of lot of data
and not just quantity of data but good
quality data data that's labeled and
curated and and represents the full
variety of the situation's you will
encounter in real life so now the good
news is there are lots and lots of these
very large publicly available data sets
which make it easy for any developer to
get started and trained powerful machine
learning models the second aspect is
that these models can be computationally
quite expensive although these are
simple computations that they're running
but they just run millions and millions
of them and so you need you know very
significant computation power to be able
to run these models in a practically
useful timeframe and now there are these
custom hardware's there are GPU advances
and new types of accelerators that are
coming up which have made it very
practical to run machine learning models
in a very very reasonable amount of time
and then lastly the research in the
field of ml has been growing and
advancing at a very fast pace there are
new publications that come out all the
time and new ways of solving problems so
basically all of these things kind of
now give everyone the ability to do this
for whatever problem you
interested in and this is where
frameworks like tensorflow come in right
so so tensorflow is an open source
library for doing machine learning and
what that means is that lot of this
mechanics and logistics of training a
model of doing this kind of back
propagation and and adjusting all the
weights of running your experiments of
creating a deployed model which can then
be deployed and used in production all
of these things are managed for you by a
library like tensorflow so you don't
have to reinvent all of this stuff it
also has a bunch of pre trained models
available that you can use off-the-shelf
right but tensorflow was written with a
Python front end right and this is where
most of the machine learning tools that
are out there today
require one to learn Python and in fact
python is termed as the language for
data science right which is unfortunate
because javascript is the most widely
used programming language and really
there haven't been too many accessible
machine learning frameworks that
JavaScript developers could use natively
in JavaScript without having to have the
burden of learning a new stack or a
completely new programming paradigm so
motivated by that we released this
library called tensorflow javascript
which is basically a version of
tensorflow that is javascript native and
so it lets you run machine learning
models and even train machine learning
models in the browser so you can run it
in in web browsers through javascript
you can run it server-side with node.js
and as we will show you you can run it
in variety of other platforms where
javascript can be used this library is
GPU accelerated and again we will talk a
little bit more about performance later
but we use WebGL acceleration in the
browser so it is very very performant
for the common types of machine learning
models and it is completely open-source
so it's it's open for the community to
use build on and extend and contribute
back into the into the library so when
we release this our hope was that this
gives web developers and JavaScript
developers back-end developers an easier
way to get started with ml and we have
been very happy actually to see the
adoption and update
this is an interesting sort of example
this person pyramids he gives a lot of
very influential talks in the JavaScript
community and he gave a talk recently at
nordic das and he sort of highlighted
some of exactly these these motivational
points that we had is that you know this
whole excitement of ml like the
JavaScript community is kind of missing
out on and now it tends to flow Jay s
you know there's an easier way to get
started and to be able to use machine
learning and in fact he says down there
that now you can bring the power of
machine learning to your web application
or JavaScript application with ten lines
of code and and sort of we love we love
this testimonial except that it's five
lines of code it's not even ten lines of
code so I'll show you that so here for
example this is how you know this is
sort of the rough template of bringing
in machine learning into your
application their first two lines of
code which are basically importing our
library and here we are showing the node
example on top so you import the TF J's
node package and the second line is
importing one of our many pre-trained
models so this is the cocoa SSD model
which is an object detection model that
is trained so that when you give it
images it will recognize a bunch of
common objects present in that image and
it will give you bounding boxes for
where those objects are right so you can
load the library on the model if you are
running this in browser then the
alternate is to just script source it
from our hosted libraries and then you
create an instance of the model which is
right there that on that first line so
basically I'm creating an instance of my
cocoa SSD model and loading it and then
I load an image and and decode a PNG
image to convert it into a form that my
machine learning model can ingest and
that's it and then I call my model
detect functions so you know model dot
detect you pass it the image object and
you get back your predictions so what
you get back you see that image on the
right it has identified a cup and a
phone and a mouse and it puts bounding
boxes on those objects and you get a
JSON object
which tells you the names of those
objects and it tells you the coordinates
of where these are and it also gives you
a probability of how confident it is of
that prediction so you know a
super-powerful model five lines of code
your web application can now be using an
object detector right and you can do
similar things with text and speech and
lots of other types of models so why is
this a good idea so on client side in
the browser there are many many
advantages of running machine learning
in client-side browser gives you a lot
of interactivity right it's easy access
to sensors like webcam and microphone
etc so you can immediately take
advantage of all this sensor data and
put it into your machine learning model
so in that object detection case for
example the images could be coming from
a webcam stream there is nothing to
install so you know you can share with
your users you just share a URL link and
they have a web page which has the model
in it and you know they download that
and they and they are using that model
directly from from that URL it has huge
privacy implications because you are
running these models locally client-side
no data is going to the server right so
for healthcare or any other privacy
sensitive type of applications you this
has enormous implications also it
reduces server side costs because you
don't have to stand up complicated
architecture sorry I lost my
projector
oh really okay I can think the connector
was a little loose yeah okay let's hope
this works and then lastly as I
mentioned that because we use WebGL
acceleration you get really really good
performance on the server side you can
you can run more powerful models that
may not be practical to run client-side
in the browser and you can basically
take full advantage of whatever hardware
you have and these could be you know
multiple code machine or GPUs or even
other custom hardware there is a very
large NPM package ecosystem so if you
are using machine learning in node you
can benefit from this whole ecosystem of
node packages and you can bring machine
learning directly into your node stack
so you don't have to have like separate
Python data science teams and a separate
back and node team who sort of are not
really talking to each other you can
bring machine learning directly into
node and have like a single stack and we
because we bind to tensorflow see
library when we run server side we get
lot of performance benefits and sort of
directly the ability to use any
conventional traditional machine
learning model that has been trained on
the Python side so there are three main
ways of using this library one is and
that object detection example was was
one example of this you can take a
existing machine learning model whether
it's a tensorflow JavaScript model or
whether it's one of your python models
and you can bring it in and run it with
tensorflow javascript second way to do
this is to take a pre trained model but
then often you have to customize it on
your own data to solve a particular
problem so we have easy ways of
retraining a model and being able to
modify it on a small amount of
additional data so that you can retrain
it and by the way another thing you can
do is if any of you are familiar with
the Google cloud auto ml service which
is a really nice cloud-based way of
bringing your own data to the cloud and
getting a custom model trained for you
with no ml expertise needed then that's
also compatible with tensorflow
javascript so you can train an auto ml
model
the cloud and get a trained tensorflow
JavaScript model that you can run and
lastly for those of you who want to
experiment and write new models from
scratch there is a full programming API
low-level programming API with
JavaScript so you are writing JavaScript
code and you can write new new models
all right so the library could use it in
any it could be used in any of these
ways because javascript is such a
versatile language and it runs on many
many platforms you can use tensorflow
J's in all these places right so you can
run it in browser you can run it on
native mobile hybrid platforms such as
react native we just recently announced
integration with react native and you
get first-class support with WebGL
acceleration through react you can run
it with node and then desktop there are
examples of people building electronics
and using tensorflow JS through electron
so so many ways of using this and we are
continuously working on adding support
for more and more platforms so as I said
we prepackaged a bunch of ML models for
common ml tasks and here are some
examples there are models for doing
image classification object detection
there are models for recognizing human
pose we had some of those demoed at our
booth and you know you're welcome to
stop by after this and see some more of
these we do pose detection there's a
very nice model for audio commands so if
you speak words it can recognize the
spoken words and you can use that to
drive actions and then we are
increasingly doing more and more around
text so text has a variety of use cases
like sentiment and toxicity and all of
these models can be either just done
used with a scripts source from our
hosted scripts or you can npm install
them so here are some more examples and
using these models as building blocks
you can build applications that solve
these types of problems like
accessibility or sentiment analysis
conversational agents and a variety of
different things so all of those
examples you are seeing on the right are
instances of models just running a
client-side so let me just take a couple
minutes and show you a very quick demo
and just to show you how easy it is to
retrain a model like this so this is a
an application called teachable machine
has anybody seen teachable machine so
far
so this is something that I would
encourage you to try out on your own
time as well after this but let's just
you know see how this works so I'm going
to skip this tutorial so this is the
teachable machine website and this will
show you how you can take an existing
machine learning model and retrain it in
in a matter of seconds so I'm going to
skip this tutorial and what you're
seeing here is a image classifier and
this web session has already loaded a
powerful image classification model
called mobile net and it's running in my
browser session and we are going to
modify this model to do very simple
rock-paper-scissors classification okay
so we're going to output the word rock
for my first class paper for second and
scissors for third okay and now we're
going to record these training images so
this green sample green class will be
rock then this would be paper and this
will be scissors and we'll just you know
record some images from my webcam so
let's record rock so I'll hold down this
button and record some training images
okay so this is rock rock now let's do
paper rock rock and now let's do
scissors paper
okay so I'm just recording some training
images right now so ignore it's
predictions scissors so now we have
trained and now it's ready so now I have
a new version of models running in my
browser so let's try it out rock paper
rock paper scissors paper rock scissors
so there you see how easy it is to train
it with like you know scissors if TMA
scissors
and the nice thing about this is that
you can very similarly train a speech
model or a pose model and now with the
new version of teachable Machine it
gives you the ability to once you have
trained this model to save it and you
can you know put it on on your shared
Drive somewhere or you can download a 80
FJs compatible model that you can run
offline so very very approachable way of
getting started with machine learning so
at this point I want to turn it over to
my colleague ping who will talk tell you
more about the API thank you thank you
turn your mic please and the core
fine-grain show you the newer Network
internally and how you be able to have
fine you know control over that's
gaining and execute and US Senate
mentioned we support most concise fusion
server-side on the class time we use
WebGL so give you automatic GPU
saturation and recently we just create a
alpha release for web assembly so give
me your better acceleration on CPU side
as well oh no side we use node.js C
binding directly into pennsville see
that way so you can use the nice sense
of law on this I don't know running in
mind and also we support GPU support how
many devices that has who does
like NVIDIA GPU parts you can use 10
afloat GPU lightweight and also we have
something called an STL view what it
does give you it that if you have and
also not volumizes you is the WebGL this
sounds weird well give you the WebGL API
actually you could use other way if you
want to so alright so now you we do give
you a lot of models right but the fact
is that you may have your own models
like you have an ml Department build
your own model all you have seen some
you know nice model outside you want to
bring into your JavaScript application
you can do that so we give you a
converter that can convert any
tensorflow models into a JavaScript
friendly format and we do a lot of
optimization for you so it can run
faster on your browser or you know
native mobile devices and we give you
also the api for you to low download
your model from like any static file
serving services like s3 or Google Cloud
storage and you can inject that interact
into your application and run the
prediction that's what you know show
earlier so that's for the browser side
but for server side we just announced a
new API there's basically if you want to
run Python model inside no now you don't
need to convert you can directly run
them using our C library and which means
you have better ops support our
converter actually support about 200 ops
the core ops of 10 to flow but actually
tenable has about thousand ops so this
give you a thousand offs so you can run
really powerful machine learning models
inside to know right now and it support
both tend to flow 1.0 version or 2.0
version and it gives you better
performance why is that because python
10 flow actually runs these I'm Thai
song so you has the Python layer it give
actually caused a lot of you know delay
but you know VA is much faster than
Python so that's why we are slightly
better than Python when you run you know
10 flow model directly inside no Jess so
here are some performer for mobile net
that's what you know sandy both showing
there's an image recognition model 10 to
flow G has give you about 20
milliseconds inference time which means
every recognition of the image takes
about 20 misses which give you 50 frames
per second if you're building a you know
like real time application that's plenty
for you to play with and TF fly if you
don't know is a native implementation
Google's another open source project it
runs on the mobile device it is
performance around like 1914 iPhone we
do have some you know performance
improvement room for improvements for
Android phone but we really working on
that so on server side you can see you
know the the know performance is very
close to the sea poplars performance so
the bow like if you get really cool GPU
you get buggy a millisecond preference
you guys ready for some code alright so
now you can build you can load your
model you can lo our pre trainer model
what about you want to build your own
model I want to show you how to do that
you first we want to tackle the
high-level API so you're probably
familiar way this is loading our NPM
packages getting our so this is loading
out no packages so baby we know magic we
have the C
- you know the tender flossy library we
also package you the C library inside
there's no npm and also you can load the
GPO version if you have GPO enabled car
let's go back to the you know image
recognition model that shown earlier so
you as sandy mentioned a typical neural
network are kind of constructed layer by
layer each layer extracts certain
feature out of previous layer and passed
on the result from to the next layer
will show you how to do that the example
will show you how to build a image
recognition model using the layer API so
it's kind of crazy writing a lot of code
but I mean to me honestly is not a bad
if you consider like using like your
curry or anything it's not more
complicated than that so here the first
thing is you use a screen shell model
what is sequential model is basically
this like 90% of the model out there are
sequential so what it means that you
layer the the layers one by one so the
next we add a couple layers those are
very typical numerical layers to combo
to D give you you know a feature
extraction type of feature and the max
pooling give you a kind of zoom in kind
of feature so baby you can look at
detail of that image at the end we will
flatten the image into a one dimensional
vector so you know the first output the
classification for the class that we
want so what this last layer will output
is a probability for each class so
that's about it I mean that's the model
we we built and then we use compile
messer to to basically set up how we
would train this model so particularly
we set up the last function to use
categorical cross entropy which you know
long name but the fact is that you don't
care and you just you know copy that the
optimizer is a
dissent is also you know easy to copy
just three letters and then take that
model now you're ready to train the
train is a very simple just one Messer
you get access you that's your input why
is this your output of your data set and
epoch is how long you're gonna run this
training session after training is done
you can of course you can look at we
have other message to show you what the
detail of the training is what the
accuracy is you know all the other good
stuff I'm kind of getting sure here but
after training is done you can save the
model to a file that's for no but you
can also save it to local storage in
browser or strip it to some server
through HTTP request so we provide a lot
of those different varieties at the end
the model is ready now you can plug it
in into your application and start you
know making your predictions so that's
high level API or what is a low level
API the low a view I actually drill down
inside the layers each layer actually is
many many smaller operations for example
there matrix-multiply there's some kind
of you know you know cost function or
something like at the cosine or sine
function or some kind of activation
function you would use I want to show
you how you can do that with ten to the
GS so let's say we have a set of data
set we want to estimate you can see
those dots those are you know kind of
polynomial you know kind of function
output but you know it's not really
perfect right so you cannot really know
what exactly the function is we want to
estimate the parameter for that function
so a B and C will be to go for us for
this model to estimate we're doing the
same thing we're loading our library we
create three variables with the initial
value at zero point one what is the
variable are the tensor that the model
gonna update the training session was
starting to
tuned to make sure the output is the
same as what we gave it to them so here
we use 10 to flowly need low level API
like say at multiply square you know
those kind of low level API you could
construct a tiny graph tiny neural
network graph so this looks a little bit
crazy right so just for a tiny little
function and just so long so we have
better way to do that so we can use
chain function chair Masser to make it
more concise to express the same thing
here we defined the last function
remember last time we just say oh it is
a categorical entropy cross entropy here
we have to define our own because we
wanted more control right so here is a
mean square error so what it does is
that calculate the difference between
your model output and you know your data
set output and then we use the same as
the SGD function the gradient descent
function - as our optimizer in the end
we manually run epochs time of
minimization of the last function so at
the end of the day is the same as what
you just saw
you know internally in the high level
API so that's about it
so for tensorflow j s we also part of
the tender flow ecosystem we not only
give you javascript also give we also
integrate it into ten the flow world we
have intensive more tender board in the
visualization to give you a
visualization of how the training
happens I give you a lot of charts to
show how the accuracy you know increase
why the training happens so those are
the at the end of the line the last line
is how you plug in into the tens abour
visualization so busy you can see in
life when you have the tangible opened
oh yeah here we go we do have a graph so
that's what do you see when the training
happened in a previous example all right
now I'll hand it back to Sandeep to talk
about our user and community thanks
Thank You ping I know we're running
almost out of time I'll just take about
three four minutes and give you show you
a couple more examples and also point to
some resources to get started so you
know tensorflow jss is a growing
community as I mentioned it's an open
source project we very sort of happy to
see the download statistics and also
seeing more and more people join as
contributors more than 200 people
contributing code actively to tensorflow
jeaious and invite and we invite you all
to become part of this and also many
developers are building really powerful
extensions and libraries on top of
tensorflow J's so there are some
examples there which let you do some
some specialized custom stuff on on top
of the library I won't show you three
examples this first one is from near
Forum and your forum is here at this
conference one of the one of the
sponsors of the conference they have
built this really nice application
called called clinic jeaious
which basically is a profiling tool so
it plugs into your node workloads and it
helps you profile and look for
performance issues memory utilization
CPU consumption things like that and in
this tool they run a tensor flow JS
model for denoising and understanding
what the what this profile data means
and you can check out a demo of this at
the at the near forum booth here at this
conference node-red is a open source
library from IBM this is a flow based
way of wiring together IOT solutions
right so you have a drag-and-drop model
and you can create IOT workflows and
node-red offers integration with
tensorflow JS so all the tensorflow JS
capabilities are easy drag-and-drop
modules that you can use to bring ml
into your iot stack and very similarly
low scient is another company that
builds enterprise grade IOT services and
solutions
and loss ant has been looking at ways of
incorporating tensorflow jeaious based
prediction for client-side edge edge
prediction of machine learning and they
wrote a really nice blog post to show
how you could use this to build like a
predictive maintenance application with
sensor data right so a lot of these
types of examples are beginning to show
the power of like an easy ml workflow in
node and iot so just in closing I wanted
to show this if you have machine
learning needs if you envision as
JavaScript developers or as know
developers if you have certain needs or
requirements from the library we would
love to get your inputs there's a
there's a UX our study that we are doing
so you know please feel free to join us
and and give us your feedback we would
love to hear from you and and here are
some links that are very useful for
getting started of course tensorflow dot
slash slash Jas that's our main website
it has all of the things examples
documentation tutorials and the link to
the github repositories up there where
we have again a lot of these examples
built we have a mailing list in red
there if you join the mailing list again
that's an excellent way to interact with
other developers and directly with us on
the tens of loggia steam one thing I
wanted to show you is that if you go to
the Google code labs and we have these
running at the Google booth outside if
you go to the Google code labs and
search for tensorflow jeaious all of our
examples are available as interactive
notebooks so you can click through this
and basically gets be up and running and
get started and explore all these
different features we talked about here
today lastly there is a new textbook
that has come out which is really a very
nice way to learn the basics of machine
learning from a JavaScript programmer
point of view all the examples in this
book are written in JavaScript so that's
something that that's worth checking out
and also we have a overarching
comprehensive tensorflow course on
Coursera which has a T of J's module now
just released this this week earlier
this week so so plenty of resources to
get started
and looking forward to you know your
your involvement in the in the community
so again thank you so much for your
attention
[Applause]